good evening ladies and gentlemen
planning west my name is Justin carriage
I'm the chair in front of me are the
counselors who are sitting on the
committee and to either side are
officers who will be advising us and if
I can ask them to introduce themselves
chambers legal services doing so I'm
bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute committee members are not
bound by a case officers recommendation
or by any oral advice Stuart's a suit
philosophy of planning officer Victoria
chatter a Senior Planner and Amy flutes
planning officer lovely so going down
the agenda apologies for absence
chairman approaches received from Cass
Atkinson for him counsel fielding is
substituting the great thank you
councillor any disclosures of interest
no so minutes I've got two sets of
minutes fifth and 26th of September are
we happy with those agreed lovely please
remind me to sign up later now we get to
the planning applications and I'm going
to change the order do I have to ask
that what can I just do that you just do
that okay so I'm gonna bring the last
I'm gonna bring item 5 which is Hardwick
house broad Lane and item 7 which is 130
Malthouse Lane URLs word-for-word so is
that done is that okay with the
commitment with the committee bring them
forward to deal with first is projection
is it just curious the reason I bring it
forward because we have no speakers
which disagree with the office of
recommendation part of the new
constitution I'm going to delegate it to
officers okay so if we go for that item
application 1800 nine nine zero outline
that's hardly cross-border lane turn
within Arden that was item five
previously I'm going to delegate that to
officers I don't need the committee's
agreement no and the previous item seven
application number 1801 85 for 130 molt
house Lane else would I'm going to
delegate that to officers as well so
thank you for turning up with you and
now we go to item number four on the
agenda which I have made an objection to
so I will sit this out and ask advice
there Molly Giles to sit in for me
this is application number 1602 2/3 3/4
lunch the rear of one 2:19 little wood
green and to the rear of Lord's Lane as
a preliminary issue committee I've been
made aware that the representatives from
some born parish council who were
consulted in relation to this
application were not given the normal in
due notice of the fact that this item
was being placed on the agenda tonight
so they would normally have been
informed
I think the Thursday before but weren't
informed till Monday some born parish
council of indicators that they would
have wished to attend and such short
notice were not able to put up a
representative to speak so I wanted
committee to consider in the first
instance I think my proposal is chair on
this item would be that we ought to
defer this item so that someone can be
given proper notice of their attendance
and so that they're able to put a
prevent representative to speak because
they have outlined that they do have
objections to this application which
continue so I would propose that and I
wonder whether as a second to that no
that's not something which has been
placed on the update sheet I was
informed of an email correspondence
between officer and Sanborn parish
council so that seconded by Councillor
all yes so can I call those in favor
thank you therefore the motion to defer
this item is granted and I apologized
very much to those who have attended in
order to give their representations but
I think we wanted to make sure that it's
a totally fair and transparent process
with everyone who has the opportunity to
participate thank you
so that's an unfortunate we have a very
brief agenda left I think we're gonna go
one planning application which is item
Oh
item six absolutely The Grange Handley
Grange Stratford Road Henley not Amy
Thank You chairman the application sites
denoted by the black dot is on the
southern edge of Helen Arden and within
Hellion Arden's built area boundary
Onion Arden is a main rule Center the
site edge Dredd is within the
conservation area but outside of the
Greenbelt a public footpath runs through
Henning Arden school playing field to
the south the school is situated to the
north east and it's Plainfield adjoins
the site to the east and south
residential dwellings are situated to
the north and west for planning
permission is sought for the
retrospective relocation of the backbone
Street Garage in addition to the
retrospective change of use of former
school Plainfield to residential garden
and the replacement of a closed boarded
fence with a two point four meter
pallasite fence together with the
implementation of an indigenous
landscape scheme the proposal would
introduce a two point four meter
palisade fence to the east and south
boundary similar to what is shown in the
top image the relocation of the bat barn
garage has been recited to the west of
the site is the same dimensions as
previously approved that the sides have
been infield as can be shown in the
bottom bottom image this image has been
taken looking south into the site from
Henry Grange the bat barn garage can be
seen in its recited position this image
is taken from within the site looking
west towards the recited garage as you
can see the sides have been infield so
this image is taken from the public
footpath which
on the school playing field looking in a
northerly direction the area subject to
the change of use is bound by the closed
bore defense which is proposed to be
replaced
this image is taken from the beginning
of the public footpath looking east
where there are some views of the
existing boundary treatment just there
chairman there are two updates on the
update sheets and the recommendation is
to grant the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed in the
committee report and updates you thank
you thank you very much and our first
speaker on this is councillor David
Tomlinson from Hellion Arden Town
Council thank you still a parish okay so
as you probably know three minutes and
I'll give you a half minute warning
there were three objections I think made
by the jpc when we received the
application first related to the
backbone and the flight path near parts
the ecologists have told us I've told
you that this isn't really an issue and
who are we to argue with that
we objected to the respective nature of
these applications because it's not the
first time that the applications we've
made in retrospect and we don't believe
that is the way to go forward good time
the third part of this is the offense be
clearly the clothes poor defense is not
liked by anybody we are concerned that
what is being proposed to replace it
inside the documentation that we've
received we've noted that it is referred
to being similar to the school
fencing when the school immediately
adjoining this property is in fact a
special-needs school and there is a very
good reason for a palisade fence there
there is a similar reason for the Henley
school although not quite as cute for
that palisade Fenster its safeguarding
of the children quite clearly we don't
believe that the palisade fence is going
to greatly improve the vision of this
part of this developed property from the
conservation area or from the Greenbelt
all the footpaths that you've already
described palisade fencing by its very
nature is quite intrusive it's designed
for a purpose and that is security it
would in our view would be much much
more appropriate to provide a linear
fence not a vertical fence bilinear I
mean something in the order of as a
traditional
from estate fence it's a tie and posting
rail can reach up to two meters if I was
necessary
they use it for gearbox it provides a
very very opening aspect and it allows
planting behind that the planting behind
would of course do something very
similar as it is proposed to contain
with a palisade fencing not produce such
a solid impact on the open space on the
Greenbelt to sell on conservation area
we note that it is capable to condition
this consent and we would ask the
committee to look at those conditions
otherwise we must still object thank you
very much ah
Cashner Thomason any any questions
cancer fielding the school which is for
security reasons because of various
reasons that you gave about special
needs why would it make any difference
if it was along the backboard you can
see on that picture you can see the
palisade there what is the difference
the difference is that the school is in
the playing fields and the school
buildings they have the appearance of
institutional buildings the palisade
fence is not out of the way when you
have a domestic property of this nature
with open space around
clearly the timber fence is like looking
at a solid block the palisade fence the
same quite made out of Steel vertical
fence and no questions I'm gonna ask
just going through what was mentioned in
the report from the Parish Council this
unilateral undertaking in the 2012
planning application to keep the site
free of enclosures do you know anything
about that I can ask officers later okay
great thank you so thank you very much
if you can put the put the button down
as well Thanks so we have no other
speakers on this request questions to
the offices oh I'm sorry
Gary Smith the applicant you were right
at the top that I didn't see you no no
no no I can't extended five you do have
three just two points I want to raise
really the the two point four meter high
palisade fence was an option we came up
with in conjunction with a men having
spent two years trying to come up with a
workable solution and as the odden field
school had used the two point four meter
palisade fence which Handley Parish
Council made no objection to whatsoever
a year ago we deemed that that would be
a suitable solution it is permeable it's
not a solid fence and as you've probably
read been also going to be doing a
planting scheme which was
often the look of that fence oh it won't
be quite as harsh it's not spike topped
it's a soft top fence and to be very in
the same way the school want to protect
their children from people for the
warmth from the children getting out and
so forth we we likewise want to protect
our property in the land from anyone
coming in so that's part of the reason
why we're looking for a two point four
meter high fence it was also a
stipulation from the school when we drew
up the license that they wanted a
substantial height fence because they
were concerned about footballs coming
over in the light so that's again part
of the reason why I use 2.4 meters the
only other thing I want you to request
rather than the state is under the
conditions it states that the fence
needs to be removed and replaced within
three months we might struggle to do
that because we're entering the
hibernation period and we've got quite a
lot of vegetation around the fence and
the skull school won't let us access our
property over the school playing fields
during turn time so we only have the
option out in out of term and the quote
that I've been given to date is about
seven to ten days work
which gives me two options Christmas and
we're still in the hibernation period or
Easter when I've got a better time so
I'd like to request I don't know how it
works whether we could have six months
rather than three months or an
undertaking that we will complete it by
the end of the easter holidays so that
we can do it in that time frame thank
you very much sir ask one question which
is kind of related to that can you give
me some on this section the section 106
was put on the planning application the
gray well properties put in for the
erection or the registry the reef Ocean
was the schoolhouse and our property
when we apply for our Planning
Commission it transpired that this
section 106 actually related to a piece
of land there was about five metres by
three metres on the edge of the car park
just outside and as a consequence of
that Mason ash and the fight League
he deemed that wasn't appropriate and it
was removed from our planning
application coupled with that the piece
of land that we're actually talking
about is actually Warwickshire County
Council's land and does not form part of
that property anyway so it's not even
relevant from that point of view okay
thank you
any other questions can't you guys I
mean I can understand what the two
competing interests here are you being
able to have security to your property
and having something which you know is a
little more pre possessing than that
which is already that I mean in an ideal
world you know the palisade fences it's
not the most attractive of things I just
wonder if you could help us understand
what other options had been looked at
and why they weren't suitable possible
yes your we'd looked at cutting the
fence in half down to four feet and then
maybe doing some kind of some sort of
trellis we looked at cutting it down to
two feet and again maybe some sort of
trellis on it but on the whole it still
wasn't permeable enough and we were
trying to find a solution we did look at
other types of fencing but they're all
in a way of sort of security type
fencing so we wanted to go for something
that wasn't spiky and to be honest with
you we were obviously looking at what
odd and field school is doing okay well
that went through that's acceptable and
we were trying to come up with something
that was in keeping with what was
already there so at least if you are
walking across the school field you'll
you'll see a consistent look of the
fence as opposed to different types so
that that's why we went down that
particular route okay no more questions
thank you very much and if you can press
the Thanks
so any questions to the officers now
castle abarnes this is an open country
so down in the Greendale correct it's
the site is within the built-up area
boundary of an Hellion Arden and the
site is outside of the Greenbelt but is
within the conservation area I can show
you I can show you a map if that's
helpful
so this is the site here and then this
is the area of land which is subject to
the change of you know the black line
denotes the built-up area boundary the
pink line is the conservation area and
the area of land which is green is the
green belt okay
Council Giles I'm just looking at the
condition about soft landscaping it says
shall be implemented in accordance with
details submitted on the specific
drawing is my understanding that the
idea of the soft landscape scheme is
it's to introduce indigenous species and
get rid of the sort of conifers it is
that what's envisaged
yes that's correct so currently there
are some conifers which have been
planted on the inside of the fence and
obviously as a result of having a fence
which is more permeable conifers aren't
something which we encourage in
landscaping schemes so as part of the
plan I can zoom in if you wish it's
intended to remove the indigenous into
it I'll just take you back to the
relevant slide bear with me so this is
an image of the garage currently and as
you can see there are some openings into
the top and if we have a look at the
plan and that they are retained as when
was originally and they are if I can
find the notes and eyebrows in roof and
to allow access for paper strips and the
second question is where is the school
say Arden field school is here and
Henley Nardin Heist
is slightly more to the north and so if
the offense running right the way around
the the school to the right don't know
if we can quite see it in my photo but
this there you go you can see the fence
so it runs runs along the east and then
it goes back on itself then in a
northerly direction okay any other
questions
no so open to debate I'd like to start
this kemp's of a bar I'm not very happy
with this mr. chairman to be honest we
battle further in in my area and other
areas not in a sensitive area like this
to keep them guarantee of a reasonable
fight and I post and Rao we've got some
so I appreciate the opposite recommend
Japanese for grant but I'm not happy at
all
okay John can you turn that off Ke$ha
Richard thanks yeah I'm entirely happy
with it I think the officers report
details everything we need to consider
and it has been considered in full and
this photo particularly helps me in my
decision-making and we have clearly a
close border defense and to the right of
it we have the existing school fence
ultimately it's going to bring a long
line that's going to be matching and
similar and will be in keeping okay
thank you
okay so Giles first I've ever said this
I'm inclined to agree with counts the
bonds I mean this fence that's already
there is really unattractive and it's
just such a shame that the only possible
of the solution is an ugly industrial
looking metal fence and I do and I
appreciate it and I'm not even saying
that I'm going to vote to refuse it I
don't know but it's just it's just a
shame you know because we're supposed to
have core strategy that looks at
enhancing the landscape and we're in a
conservation area we're bounding green
boat and we're supposed to be looking at
things which are just nice to look at
and it doesn't do that and I appreciate
there is a tension here but I understand
why household a want security you know
shame I suppose one of the only
mitigating features is that indigenous
soft planting may in due course sort of
obscure it but I know we have this sort
of fessing over our shastri field and it
does it's an attraction it's not it's
not that pleasant ok cannister fielding
I think because yes that fencing is not
attractive and it is too high but on the
other hand the school the school
requested sound quite happy to 2nd okay
thank you so I've got a proposing a
seconder but I'll just hear from Council
organ if she I'm fairly ok about the
change of use because there's obviously
existing trees within the playing fields
that means that this area of land is
probably not useful playing fields and
Sport England don't object so I don't
have a problem with that
what I do have a problem with is the
planting for the palisade fencing
because I think that is the key to it
that it is a proper planting scheme that
is properly planted and the sooner the
better
now if you look at the recommendation
and there is the I'm pleased to see the
caveat that if any is destroyed or
desired dies and it has to be replaced
but it is quite clear that the planting
season really for this kind of thing is
from October to March I'm not quite sure
where it when Easter is so and why the
hibernation season means it can't be
done before Easter I'm not quite sure
why that is
ok
I think we might have to get officers on
something about that okay officers
couldn't Liam can we have some comment
on well one the proposal that you know
there's a there's a length and time
allowance if if it was granted to
install the new fence because of
constraints with the schools allowing
them on when the bird nesting season and
that in relation to planting a new a new
soft landscaping
and we've obviously this application is
retrospective and we consider that a
condition allowing three months for the
fence to be replaced is reasonable
obviously there are a number of school
holidays between that time and I know
Christmas isn't necessarily the easiest
but it's potentially possible that it
could be done at Christmas with regards
to obviously hibernation I know that the
the bird nesting season runs February to
August and then I think I recommended a
a note that obviously if there are any
and birds found then of you obviously it
shouldn't carry on forever until until
they have left ok so I obsess to me like
we don't change the conditions that's
the recommendation from the officer and
which is no no ok right we've got a
proposed that we've got a second to go
with the office of recommendation and
the conditions that are suggested in the
report all those in favor and all those
against ok this committee has resolved
to grant planning permission 17:03 105
full the Grange handling now thank you
very much any other business already
no urgent business
okay well this is brilliant half past
six
how strange